- You know, here's the thing.
In July, it was two years
since I've had a drink,
because, two years.
- Oh!
- Because as we said, I don't
think I'm gonna have grandkids
for many, many years and when they come,
I'll probably be about 75,
and so I need my brain.
I don't want to be that drooling
grandmother in the corner,
you know, that you have to go
kiss and then run away from.
I want to be at an active level, you know.
So I haven't been drinking
to preserve my brain, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- However, it doesn't seem
to have helped that much,
because...
(laughing)
the other night, I get a
text from my youngest son
and he says, "Well, happy
birthday to me, I guess."
And I realized--
- My mother did this once!
- And not only was it his birthday,
it was his 21st birthday.
- Oh no!
(Patricia laughs)
- I'm at the top of the stairs.
This was before the pandemic,
so he was still at school.
(laughing) I yelled
down the stairs, "Dave!
"We forgot Dan's birthday!"
Dave was like, "Oh my God."
So I, and it's 21st birthday,
so I felt so, so bad...
That I started texting every
celebrity friend that I had
and I gave them Dan's phone number.
And I said, "Please,
will you text my son Dan?
"It's his 21st birthday, I forgot.
"Please just text him,
wish him happy birthday.
"Tell him I'm a terrible parent."
And Dan was very impressed.
First of all, his roommates
at college were very impressed
that Ashley Tisdale was texting him, so--
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, she's so nice!
- So nice, and she was having
a conversation with him.
She told me later, her husband
said, "Who are you texting?"
And she said, "A bunch of college boys."
(laughing)
But the best one was Ray
Romano sent me a video,
or sent Dan a video and
then he sent it to me.
And it's really funny what
he said, I think you have it.
- Hey Dan, I know it's a little noisy.
I understand it's your 21st birthday,
according to my calendar.
I guess your parents don't have
the same calendar than I do,
but I keep track of things,
so happy 21st birthday.